welcome to this video coverage paid for
round two form of the candidates and
yeah
but now we have some idea who is in good
shape and bad shape and we have yeah
also some defined tournaments standing
after three rounds and we see that arms
is on plus two unexpectedly leading the
tournament and Kramnik is on plus one so
on a fine game against kayaking before
but was in big trouble against Peter
Svidler
in round three and only escaped well
with a somewhat miracle defense that he
added that he managed to find it was
absolutely not easy to do so a great
safe but nevertheless he was in trouble
could have easily lost this game so we
must feel good to sort of yeah escaped
from this this critical situation let's
see what happened in this game are not
having white so we can expect a type of
game where certainly both players would
love to win it would be excellent but
they have a good standing in the
tournament at the moment they don't
really need to risk much so let's see
what happens on unplaned d4 this was
somewhat unexpected and well chronic
puts the first moves on the board
quickly plays that basically anyway as
part of miss Maine repertoire but yeah a
lot play tonight f3 and well even d4 is
of course a slight surprise are not
being primarily 1.e4 player but here
kramnik was slightly taken aback I this
time had the possibility to watch some
of the the live video stream so I could
see that here chronic thought for a
moment he yeah maybe had in mind that
recently
and played before yet played 93 allowing
the the names of for example in that
game it was game 9 in the World
Championship match against Carson he had
played this a three line which is some
an ambitious attempt certainly by white
and leads to sharply at yeah this time
it was 93 and after some thought kramnik
went for 45 yeah he is not exclusively a
Queen's Gambit player here he sometimes
plays b6 but it's it's rare so this was
to be expected if you look at it from
Holland's perspective 93 and t8 he took
a walk ramnik because this is of course
sort of a cross road situation black iam
has many playable moves and to be honest
scrum League has played most of them at
some point or other in his career there
is a c5 the samurai tirage which he
recently added to his repertoire sort of
a solid ma'am of a solid choice this
Bishop e7 the classical Queens gambit
which is the most solid way to play
maybe even if you look at the whole g4
complex this is just very very solid and
this for example had been discussed in
the World Championship match between
those two players in 2008 we're honored
that played Bishop f4 in one of the
games um
Kramnik in his early the early days of
his career he had lots of games with the
semis Slav leading to sharply this also
is the possibility he has still he's
still playing that that opening but I
guess being a somewhat surprised by
Ana's choice he wanted to play a line
that maybe Arnold was wasn't expecting
and he went for D take C form this is in
fact a relatively popular line on the
top level you see your games popping up
every couple of month even now in on the
highest level and in fact this is one of
those lines that does not really yeah
have a name it is sometimes called the
Vienna variation the Queen's Gambit but
I don't think this is technically true
the true the Vienna variation arises
only after the next couple of moves but
again this is just a technical issue
it's not so important for the game yeah
what is black doing it sort of plays
that like a Queens gambit accepted just
taking on c4 but something has happened
white already has a knight on c3 which
does not really happen in the Queens
gambit accepted so well so quickly so
White's choice yeah it's a bit yeah
let's say limited I don't play d4 which
is my father the means the thing is if
you play e3 like you very often do in
the Queens gambit accepted your knight
is sir on c3 very early on and this is
believed to get to be helpful for black
who very often plays with something like
that it's just this on the board
possible before might highlight that the
knight on c3 is not so well placed at
least that early on it basically comes
down to to this position after DC 44
that's the most ambitious way to play
which V she did no Bishop before you
know attacking efore with this by
setting up the spin the idea Bishop g5
is by father
the main move for a while Bishop takes
e4 was was a hot move just gamba ting
this pawn
but I guess for this tournament
situation this is just not the right
opening for four are not who already is
on plus two plus he certainly could not
expect exactly this line from Kramnik so
he went further for the main
continuation Bishop g5 no c5 is plate
and Bishop takes c4 yeah there are
alternatives but this is believed to be
best played by both sides crumbling took
on default and Knight takes d4 yeah him
we can again go back to the World
Championship match 2008 between chrome
League and Holland and this time it's
Calais reverse chronic was right in one
of those games and are not playing black
so we have reversed reverse roles in
that game are not had played Queen a5
which at the time was a slightly
slightly surprising it's a it's a
sideline and still um probably can be
called a sideline it wasn't so
surprising to me it was one of those
cases where this was a line that I had
analyzed him a while before and that was
quite quite excited to see that plated
the world championship match yeah this
is what what anna played this plaque I'm
not sure if I should go to to details of
that game he relatively quickly
equalized but white had and the return
has found some my improvements to still
press so Kramnik went for the main line
he took on c3
and twin a for Eva a5 and now we see
that all this leads to very concrete
plain black it's attacking c3 with a
check and the taking of the bishop and
it's already impossible for white to not
to not sacrifice a pawn it's simply too
much hanging and white must now select
how to give a
upon and the bear farmers come and move
is what what Alan played he played to
just check on v5 the main line there's
also the month night b5 which is still
an option for why this had been played
by couple for example against amongst
others against Jan Timman in his work
Shepherd should mention 1993 but they
discussed the main line this was a check
97 Bishop d7 is also moved but believed
to be somewhat worse 97 and now white
took on f6 so one liability this Bishop
is given up to take and damage black's
pawn structure but of course it's
important that black can give this
intermediate check and this is one of
the the main points of blacks play he
with this check can force the white king
to go to everyone and give up castling
rights GF and this is a position that
has been discussed really lots of times
and yeah obviously it's a sharp position
white has sacrificed upon the corner on
c3 who got lost with a check but on the
other hand likes King is only eight it's
in the middle of the board and whatever
black is trying it will be difficult for
him to find a absolutely safe place for
his King very tricky you sometimes end
up only 7 here which can be quite safe
place but it's not like yeah just that
the King is sitting sitting yeah in the
in the corner of the bar being protected
by pawns by pieces you know black always
needs to be a bit a bit aware officer
creakle King situation okay so what's
White's move here I applied h form this
for a long time has been established as
being the most testing move it has more
than one idea the main idea of course is
to play rook f3 and get this rook into
the game which is obstructed by his own
king white has lost castling rights and
while this is believed to be the the
best tribe commonly played a6
immediately attacking the bishop and
after this tempo gainer drop back to
before yeah the bishop on b5 is hanging
that's not but else really you need to
to need to retreat it so back to e2 and
now 95 yeah I am
I did some some reach the research about
about this disposition because I'm
around here it's clear that yeah that
alternatives need to need to be need to
be checked yeah what what should do I do
what obviously wants to get some flame
again the black king is possible and
possible inroads can be the geophone
like that of course the CFR and black
can yeah black wants to mobilize the
species upon up I mean he manages to to
exchange some some pieces he might have
chances in the endgame to even play for
win with this with this pawn yeah what
on our plate assume is h5 this has been
tried before and I guess it has multiple
ideas it takes away in the bone square
for the knight possibly and well if you
win the H pollen 1/7 the H 1 is 1 1
square
closer to promotion which is of course
yeah based on the hope that this might
might happen sometime in fact h5 is
certainly a useful move but it's not
necessarily the um yeah the only one I
also found a game Guri shock and scrum
neck gromek has played this before but
it's not one of his main openings
Roxy one is the move that Grisha played
in this position and Kramnik responded
with Knight Queen to d6 the idea of
Queen d6 is twofold one might be to play
ninety six at one stage to pressurize
the night just one idea of just to take
a look at the night so that white needs
to do protect it and another idea might
be if this rook was ever going to switch
over that the Queen maybe has h2 as an
attacking square in this mansion game we
should plate Roxy to and after the 57 he
went for Ruby - yeah in fact it's that
that's quite logical you get some
pressure on the D fall and threaten
discover the text ya Kramnik here went
for Queen to c7 and he agree she played
Roxy - and you might get the sneaky
suspicion yes you are right they agreed
to draw here after this perpetual and in
fact this is one of those lines there's
this general concept of this line that
it is it is very sharp it is concrete
and it very often sort of fizzles out to
repetitions perpetual checks and so on
because comparable to 2 to sharp
Sicilian lines very often the wood
energy is put into into the into the
concrete play and sometimes it just
evaporates in
Danelle to those kind of repetitions or
something like that this is one of those
cases well and I didn't want to do it so
quickly and allow some repetition he
wanted to continue and finally played h5
so chronic back to the sixes was known
to him this retreat maneuver he had
played it before himself after all
Yaya Allen played Queen d2 which is a
very logical way to continue as the
queenís looking at those critical dark
squares the dark squares are the weekend
squares and then blacking in blacks camp
so yeah Queen e2 was very sensible in
fact here kingi one is also mix that had
been played before against one of the
best u.s. players Yuri Schulman played
this is white against German top player
card in a ditch and after King g1
knighted she went for Bishop d7 and
later he played rook da Dan b5 or this
was very very complicated he actually
won the game neither did he gained the
upper-hand later but very complicated as
I mentioned and King g1 it looks a bit
it looks a bit slow I I don't really
know I only had a brief look at this
with with the computer going over some
moves it's always yeah giving this
position about equal sort of dynamically
equal I guess balancing the the plusses
and minuses balance balancing each other
out White has compensation for the pawn
but probably not more than that yeah I
don't played Queen d2 I like this move
it's it's going to the to the right
color complex and just make much sense
in my book
yeah 96 was played attacking the knight
and yeah what we should ride to
playgroup d3 this makes also lots of
sense other moves are really not
apparent if you play something like
group d1 some some still move yeah oops
you run into vicious double attack and
of course you don't want to move the
night this is just getting to a position
where if any kind of compensation has
just evaporated cannot exchange Queens
so route d3 is pretty much the only move
to play yeah and here we see oops
go into h2 a maneuver that I mentioned
before and this is one of the reasons
why Sherman went for the scheme g1 is to
prevent this kind of thing from
happening yeah Black is just cheekily
threatening made in one and yeah what
should Y do it's really somewhat
unpleasant already because you don't
have so many available moves interesting
enough this is still a position that had
been played only in 2012 in a game by
two Austrian players and white players
called service against hurts - I am
strength players how it's actually isn't
I am I'm not sure about the white player
but he's 2400 rated yeah here the white
player played Knight f3 taking the Queen
check and after that went for this
retreat so he just has transferred the
knight from D for all the way to g1 not
so great yeah but yes gains something
the queen is on a somewhat questionable
a critical Square and in fact it wasn't
so clear or he played rook g8 now
this the black player hood sir attacking
on g2 and yeah it's not so yeah I don't
really have a great move to cover it
there's route g3 and this is what the
white player went for after this play d5
yeah and this is really weird position
the Queen is completely off-site it
cannot easily retreat to do blacks camp
but on the other hand yeah black enjoys
upon and he's got this strong square
available it's it's really not so clear
this position I mean maybe something to
to explore for for white but there are
multiple alternatives if five is for
instance not strictly necessary black
can also examine 95 or first Bishop d7
and possibly long castles yeah
complicated 7 this is an alternative
that white can can go for but it does
not look too great to retreat off the
way to g1 yeah Allen played F for him
and we see by the time spent that this
was already yeah I guess plate plate
only someone is not relying on any
preparation he couldn't really guess
that chrome neck would play this Vienna
line but he certainly has some general
knowledge about this because also as I
mentioned he had played the the lioness
black so it's probable probably he ya
headed analyzed at some point but needed
to remember what so what's going on it
was rechecking things okay f4 so um this
looks a much sharper than Knight to f3
and at first we need to of course
firstly to check what happens if black
just grabs the rook here yeah in fact
after Knight takes c6 white has fled out
winning
this is too much 58 yeah black and
castle and sort of sack hang on for a
while but after route d8 it becomes
clear that black is is just lost here
you cannot play queen h1 simple as that
you need to do something else and
crumbling is playing the right movie
plays rook g8 using the g5 for concrete
counter play yeah and there is not not
much choice
push about three is what we she played
here you can calculate Knight takes c6
now you can do that but look what's
happening check check the White King
needs to go all the way to two to e3 and
after this check check check
black is in excellent shape the easiest
probably is route g1 check and exchange
Queens then you are two points up and
it's it's not in super trivial because
White has some activity but black should
win this yeah you need to cover g2 it's
a it's just like that Bishop III played
bias by Anand
now chromatic played Bishop to d7 so you
guys ready to play relatively quickly
so this is probably a really historic
art of his preparation Bishop d7 and 92
yeah preparation not for the single game
but probably is general prep
yeah 92 this does not look so
self-evident why 92 why we treat the
problem is that the black is threatening
to take and play Bishop b5 check if y
place yeah
so move like that let's for instance
playbook c1 black takes check and give
this check guarantor now the king
is in some trouble he needs to go here
and then just play Bishop c6 very good
place for the bishop covered anchored by
the pawn and just holding the whole
position together yeah Black has queen
g3 possibly and he is caught in extra
pawn on top of all of that so just a
good position for black a real threat
that white needs to reckon with the
capture and Bishop b5 check yeah he
retreated the night which is perfectly
acceptable move and now it gets very
interesting check prominent places check
and of course we first need to check
what happens if after this check white
is playing king of two always needs to
be checked
can we sacrifice it it's you know it has
some some dangerous look to it but rook
d8 is just terrifying things White has
no way to continue of the check oh sorry
so bad
check yeah of course Najee one is the
move that you need to play yeah and in
fact we've come to a position that you
if you if you like you can look at this
and take this as a calculation exercise
look look at it and try to find the best
move for black okay I'm going to tell
you the move now so last possibility to
to stop the video black really only has
one good move here and went for that
this is ninety four very very funny move
just putting it in the middle of the
board despite them square being
controlled by white pieces this is just
by far the best moves and it's leading
to a fast draw as managed as mentioned
this is quite often happens in this
sharp type of lines it is really the
best move black yarn has a hard time to
try to avoid it and play for a win the
human for example consider castles long
playing g3 oops and the queen is trapped
so this is very important to note that
this is actually a substantial threat so
black cannot afford any yeah any slow
moves and his strengthening move
something like that is just not possible
note that also d7 is just hanging so
what chromic did he played Knight to
deform yep here which is absolutely the
only move but the move that saves the
day it introduces the Bishop b5
possibility which is also the major
threat here now and
what just needs to take on before no
there's nothing else as Bishop b5 a
threatening in any case check yeah we
should be b5 check and King f2 was
played yeah can bite somehow avoid that
no he really can't Bishop e2 is just
check checkmate
just too embarrassing so what else is
there I figure route III yeah well
that's route d8 talk about a deadly pin
yeah there's just not anything else King
f2 is played Channel Queen h4 check and
now we see this Bishop is controlling
the light squares
the queen is checking on the dark
squares so there's really nothing else
King III you need to go forward now e5
this is a point the point of all that to
secure the draw it is an attack on the
rook and it's clearing the dark square
so black ya can always give checks now
this is what happened Queen g5 check
chant again a check here and white only
has III to go to those two squares are
secured by the bishop check yep check
check
yeah this is exactly how it went down at
here we had the draw agreed yeah bit of
a somewhat disappointing way to to
finish at this game but it's still a
really logical course of the game and I
didn't really I guess didn't really
expect this precise line and there are
some ways to to make a draw here even
earlier if you just for example I
mentioned this this game boy agree
shocked yes
Kramnik but also note that if you look
at this I'm sorry come in here exactly
this position when he played the mood
f-for white also has a very simple
choice rook h3 Queen b6 rope d3 and this
is even an earlier draw so he only tried
the utmost and from she needed to find
know whatever those moves are grouped if
like like 94 so on but I draw certainly
it is not that both players can can live
wit can live with easily they are both
in contention for the more important
first place
Anand with +2 Kramnik with +1 so yeah
some more fireworks would have been nice
but it is not supposed to happen
and there's mentioned very
understandable from a tournament
strategy point of view I hope you
enjoyed the game anyway thanks for
watching